yeah that's delightful pretty good well
Rob I gotta give you a shitty it is
idiot I do we bring all wait oh yeah oh
I'm spazzing owl up we get new rides you
know what I'm Oh what is placing an
interceptor all god what we do on me and
interest shoot him you mean like this
shouldn't want to rock it all right I
got rockets live another anything else
there's only two of them I'm gonna be
slow there's three the other Torian I
shouldn't have done this yeah I'm dead
you guys can get on that oh god no Laura
so I kind of blew it there's a Centurion
in their sins broken it's got like some
sports trends hahaha what out of here
eat it you big dummy BAM you is anyone
got another one you want the broken one
nah you want this broke-ass one nah
gotta get broken Rob handlery get right
broke it scrub come on is only mildly
broken damn that boost is so tight yeah
oh man Doug oh my god i'm not good at
driving that same not good either i
gotta stay a little bit further away
that's right i checked up my rod is that
pervin our objective as we need one of
this now an ermine just have a sick ride
I hope not cuz I need to blue has our
life objective at all times is to have a
sick ride supercharged BAM oh so much d
agent you go Oh knifed you could take
anything and make it a [ __ ] tonight
goodnight oh you got a knife to basic
imagic this guy so hard space magic
everybody in Lamar's get night alright
guys well just dude he's got like a
minigun ourselves a colossus
yeah I need some heavy ammo oh jeez
selling to drive well okay all right I
was gonna continue to ball bargain one
Bartman Sunday and everything we got
have your shield like that phalanx
look at our dough
whoa
yeah get jacked up get jacks
oh no it is on fire dang his [ __ ] is on
finds the song goes at lyrics my [ __ ] is
on fire I try to boost smash this guy
this is the worst idea I've ever heard
oh my god I guy hahahahaha would you do
if I knocked it back so far we didn't
kill me in my ride and my ride is on
fire still in a bad way open up door
supercharged with no special
yeah it's got there not singin destiny
you're not living where are you going
buddy aah whoa I'm gonna go back and see
if I can get now another one of those
sweet rides better be no one here got in
the given from above all here it is this
it yeah I'm gonna be big I'm gonna get
my super from up here not one yeah the
respawn and his chest right here don't
like those dopes really good [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop shooting me a jerk just such a
massive target with this thing
come up here you big dumb idiot we
rounding into a rock Oh someone on that
ride a rep behind you Jen oh here god
I'm gonna forget he'll respond boom I
get you with some head jorts correct oh
you're almost dead Oh what I'm feeling a
bit along just thought he ran away he
ran away what a jerk all right I need to
investigate what this chain of war was
all about noise guys almost done help me
out mm-hmm where are you right Rob uh
it's like cliff Rajesh killed increase
weapon reloads be he go he's almost dead
his shields down I she'll want backup
god damn it go do that
yeah I thought the other is get him I
want him dead I want you to kill that
guy
come on one of the time to reload there
it is Hammer hammer it is still one left
in here the big guy there it is what's
gonna be going on I wait totally dodged
my oh yeah midair shot oh [ __ ] there is
guys want to come in here you have some
you having some fun dude is in here mr.
at a party centurion centurion party
doesn't her play with the mighty that
fire water walking how just over to talk
black cannon or something lacking oh
look at that thing oh that's one of
those guys are just deal with these his
brother chipping away at I'm gonna stuff
guys shield yeah shields close guys
don't worry about it i'm just gonna take
this ride and go away I'm not gonna try
to kill you Oh almost he did not believe
me Oh she'll came back yeah that's quick
oh yeah I was going we're very sensitive
about me stealing their ride
is what I'm talking about Robbie sillier
yep I Sheila's gonna be down in a second
yeah this is it's now yeah it's tight
it's down [ __ ] yep keep hammering OH get
cover [ __ ] oh you're kidding me down dog
benguet kind of y'all get you here Eddy
Cue yeah
all that she'll get back up too late
whoa he's alive yeah I'm having this
ride friendo Oh Marius she's down [ __ ]
oh you're down yeah guys I'm sorry i've
gone down a rabbit hole Oh desperately
trying to steal this ride from like a
whole pack of you
[ __ ] this how's your head [ __ ]
heavy weapon where are you may I missed
him on my rocket all right oh ok I think
it's down oh you need [ __ ] where is he
oh hi no yeah keep doing that is he is
he's shield am yeah almost killed it
down yeah it is oh this is it I'll space
magic oh he's done Walker get I'm coming
in to spruce music nice dead like my red
sick ride thanks very cool already
smoking yeah yeah was it worth it so we
call a handler this is we draw the
handlery the drill cool are we going
here this way i think Danny's got the
idea just as user space bikes well I'm
supercharged
look at that over ain't that super
respawning restrictive mmm hello all you
can't bring it in hahaha wow you don't
worry oh you don't you're too fat no
don't worry guys I got this you want to
try and ramp up me or something
basically oh this is mega renovation
yeah oh i think i might break see if he
can ramp up me that's a good idea they
should go well go up some balls and I
look like a kind rat can I lift you yeah
here we go give me over this rock I'm
not leaving my ride if we both did with
you might be able to get in okay guy on
your bike doing dumb crap come on let's
go you can I can't do it in this
location let's be quick [ __ ] i'm not i
don't i don't know four hours later hope
it fine can't take it anymore alchemy I
can't get all my stuff that's weird good
luck now we're in the restricted zone it
took your license away Rob because of
all of the drinking damn it well Chris
sir listen you don't need to beat up my
ride just because I can't bring you like
a trip